You will know as well as I do that
wealth taxes have been tried in a number
of countries. Only Switzerland has stuck
with it. I mean, they've got no capital
gains tax. They got no inheritance tax.
They got a slightly different situation.
But most countries have abandoned them
because they they don't bring in that
much revenue. What makes you think it
would be different here? Fiona, we did
it here. We did it here. We did it here
in the ' 50s, the 60s, the 70s, and
people like my dad, people like my
granddad, who was a bus conductor, were
able to buy houses, have financial
security, have pensions, have
retirements, go on holidays. We did it
here. We did it here. And we're losing
that now because we're not taxing the
rich. The rich are getting richer. and
ordinary families are losing the ability
to buy houses, have kids. We can do it.
We've done it before.